YouTubeチャンネルが、
あの、5万人登録達成しておりました。
ああは。
いつも見てくださってる方のおかげでついに
5万人までくれる方が増えまして。
えっとね、これは愛国心から出ることで、だから諸君も愛国心を強くしてどんどん広げてくれ。そうしたら日本は救われる。今のリーダーども。あれは暴のだ。特にマスコミ。マスコミが日本のリーダーになったからこんなことになったんだ。で、考えてごらん。
戦争で持って日本はゼ0よりマイナスに
なったんや。そいつを何十年間で世界1に
しちまったやん。世界一にしちまった人は
戦前に教育を受けた人たちだ。そうやね。
せっかく世界一にしてくれたのに戦後に
教育を受けた我々が今良くて30、この前
38位だ言っとったな。今もっと下がっ
とるやろ。そのうちに100位になっ
ちゃうよ。自分たちが悪いと思わないの。
だったら何が悪いんや。教育が悪いに決まっとるじゃん。だから教育は早くちゃんとしないと日本潰れるよね。
ちょっと外チャンネルとかで質問があったと思うんですけど、あ、今後の校調の活動とかあとこの令和ヨットスクールでの今後のやりたいこととかあったら是非伺いたいです。の味方を国民の半数以上にすりゃ部大臣は民できるし、マスコミは潰すことができる。ともかく朝日と毎日を潰さんことには日本は助からんよ。
校長の教育の正常化のためには僕たちでこう正しい発信をしっかり影響力をつけていくっていうのと、ま、同時にリベラルをこう排除していくっていうのもやりたいことの
1つなんですね。うん。
だけどリベラル排除はみんなでやらんと難しいよね。文部省に言ってリベラルの人は先生にしないということでもやってもらわんとね。
外チャンネル拝見したんですけど調がなんか僕のこと
30代っておっしゃってたんで。
あ、そうやったか。[笑い]
前お会いした時大学生って言われて
半年後外チャンネルで30代[笑い]
一応25歳で
やらせてもらってるんで
今から頑張ってもらう世代やね
はいはいあの
君たちが頑張らんと我々はもうダメやからねあと
10年もできやしない
はいこのチャンネルもどんどん影響力を拡大していって
いやそうやね
いい風に力を使っていければと思っておりますね結局ねリベラルは聞きたくないから俺の話なんかねそこ
で、止まっちゃうよね。お前ら間違っとったんやぞということを一生懸命言っとるわけやからな。それは嫌よね。連中はあいつらが日本の死身中の虫だ。リベラル大反対。リベラルを潰せ。
最後おまけというか、あの、個人的に嬉しかったのが学校の先生とかテレビの言うことを聞いててちょっと、
ま、うつ病とまではかないんですけど、ふぎ込みがちだった方がなんかたまたま面白でこのチャンネル見てくれて、
すごい今体調が良く、心の状態が良く目から鱗で救われましたってコメントをいて
そうやね。
前もあったね、うつ病かなんかになっとった人が精神家にい続けて薬を飲み続けてたけど俺の話を聞いて薬も飲まんようになった精神家にも行かんようになった。
そうしたらば家族とまくいくようになったと。
うん。
家族とも子供ともうまくいくようになった言っとったね。
はい。
だからあれもリベラルの罪だ。
こんな言い方すると捏造だろとかやらせだろうってまた言われそうなんですけど本当に結構コメントで若い人からそういうことだくこと多いんですよね。
若い連長犠牲者やからね。からもうともかくみんなでリベラル教育をやめさせようよ。そうしたら全てがうまくいくんだということは日教争はもう全部潰しちまう。朝新聞は潰す。あれはリベラルやからね。
最後に来年の目標とか何かやりたいこととかあったら伺いたいです。
結局ね、今うちがやっとる幼事トレーニングを伸ばしていきたい。だから結局ね、みツの魂
までということをよう考えないかんのや。ところが密つになるまでに甘やかし放題やろ。だったら一生甘えるんや。それまでにちゃんとトレーニングしてやるということをね。
はい。
もう1
つは子供の世界を取り上げちまって子供が団体になって外でわーっと遊んどるなんてそういう場面ないやないか。
遊園地に行ったってお母さんたちが周りを取り囲んであの子のと指示しとる。いじめたらいかんとかいじめるどうのこうのとか自由に遊ばしたらにゃん子供は本能的に行動しとるから正しいことをやっとる。
来年はとりあえず幼少教育の方の中力と
うん。幼児教育についても少しね
あの話をしていかんと
あそうですね。YouTube
の方も引き続き来年もよろしくお願いいたします。
Eh